has gum breastplates beautify welcome to
five nights at freddy's 4 oh boy am I
excited so excited leave a like it to
show your excitement you all know the
drill we can just start playing five
days until the party can't wait for the
party
alright Iran Iraq look at my boat I love
wearing bowties what did he do this 10 I
don't know you lucked you in your room
again
I kind of like being in my room it's
okay don't be scared I'm here with you
semi crying like a little [ __ ] these
are my friends just like a prequel that
it like a fabulous I walk fabulous
you think it's fabulous don't lie to me
let me out place I've been a good boy
well I better lay down and touch my
ovaries cuz I'm a little [ __ ] sorry
okay what okay well that was five nights
at Freddy's 4 hope you enjoyed it feel
free to leave a like
the game tells you to put up your audio
it's literally maximum but it's still
not loud maybe that's a trick for later
tomorrow is another day
Wow I'm glad we went through that night
one so I'm just laying crying and this
is weird I don't know what's going on
click here to run to the door click here
to run to the door click here to run to
the door turn around downward to look
behind you control man what an ugly ass
find okay not sure if I understand but
I'm sitting in my room
scared for something I mean I was locked
out a second ago I don't [ __ ] get it
ok so you run through the closet that's
kind of cool and then you run back why
not just stay in the closet kind of
creepy kind of like the idea we'll see
how it holds up I don't know are you
scared
you tell me that's a great lamp
fantastic lamp look at the shape I like
some curves if you know what I mean that
robot is [ __ ] awesome too Oh
so far absolutely nothing what's so
[ __ ] ever is happening what are the
sound cues I don't I haven't really
picked up on now so this is just what I
do all night see here where my
flashlight could just turn on the
[ __ ] lights but [ __ ] that all right
this is what I do this is my life
this is how I'm loving it I bet
nothing's gonna happen the first night I
gotta be a really pissed off at nothing
happens the first night Wow okay
yes I'm I'm happy four days until the
party this party better be the best damn
party ever
you know he's heading again ah damn I
get down from that teddy
yeah damn you crazy-ass mofo oh look a
flower
you look so perverted like yeah I'm
checking out that is look at that fine
sweet [ __ ] ass yeah that's right that
ass oh my god foxy you [ __ ] it's like
Fox's like I'm gonna finger you and then
I'm gonna look at that ass I'm sorry
that's what it looks like I don't know
what that hand gesture is not a pervert
you said it first
yes you did don't talk back to me how
[ __ ] dare names Kate how long is he
gonna cry I don't understand alright
night two am I having fun yes yes are
you having fun we're having fun together
not in a weird way
there's does that mean something go away
no what I don't understand
I'm trying at least but I really feel
like this is amazing
it's blowing my mind it's a great carpet
great choice of toys and again the lamp
sound like somewhere right over here so
hello oh are you over here hello oh okay
well I don't [ __ ] know that go away
little teddy things thank you
appreciated
oh yeah I'm helps yourself to some
chicken yes stay away from my sexy lap
oh it's another sexy lap there hey we
can have one each come on share the
lamps cuz I'm I always said I've never
ever said that going am I having fun
III don't understand why anyone wouldn't
have fun [ __ ] what did I do wrong
this my wedding this correct sound came
from right all right [ __ ] it
if you play the first three games you're
practically immune to the jump scares by
now
like there's no [ __ ] way unless you
really caught off guard that's one sexy
ass beast look at that [ __ ] [ __ ] hot
I like the idea of a sound cues though I
gotta say that's that's pretty clever
but it seemed like he's scaled down on
other things okay definitely heard him
over here don't jump-scare
okay well that I mean I don't the thing
is like everyone wants me to play this
game to get scared but after four games
it's I don't know what to tell you you
know there's just gonna be jump scares
if there's something else than that then
maybe I'll be scared but it's like if
you know what to expect then four times
then they just kind of like over go away
I don't know my favorite game a whole
time I keep saying how much I love this
game alright uh Nev I played it
and so good I love it so much thank you
guys for watching leave a like for the
next part and say awesome dress